Vast stretches of Ukraine's
famously fertile farmland
pockmarked with craters
and the tailfins of unexploded r
long after Russian
and Ukrainian soldiers move on,
they leave behind
another deadly threat
just below the surface.
So Alexander's brought me here
to see something
that's actually, frankly,
a little uncomfortable
because right over here
on the side of the road
or, I don't know, maybe ten,
what appear to be tank mines.
My guide is a local
farmer named Alexander Luke.
Oh, okay.
We've got more anti-tank mines h
You can see there's one, two,
three, four, five
anti-tank mines
right here on the side of the ro
I got to the way that you said t
he says, I brought them out of t
and placed them right here.
This 69 year old
farmer says he's desperate to pl
seeds before spring
but can't because his fields are
with land mines,
some of which he found
with this metal detector
and dug out with his own hands.
By Gaza, Myanmar, a huge he said
I was afraid,
but I need to plant these fields
Both the Russian
and Ukrainian militaries use lan
Some designed to take out 40 ton
Lifting mines is extremely dange
There's
nothing
until this device is designed
specifically to do.
And to kill an injured
people who try to do that.
Murray Cunningham of the deminin
Halo Trust says
Ukraine is now littered
with a terrifying variety
of explosive devices.
We're seeing anti vehicle mines.
We're seeing anti-personnel
mines, anti-personnel
bandaging fragmentation
mines on trip wires
and grenades on tripwires.
And we're also seeing cluster mu
The Ukrainian military
estimates nearly
a third of the country
is now
contaminated with explosive devi
But clearing
them is slow and dangerous work,
and the war is still
being actively fought.
Littering the
countryside with new explosives
every day.
Ukraine is one of the world's
great breadbaskets.
Every week,
it seems
there are reports of farmers
like this man
badly wounded in a blast
while trying to plant his fields
Alexander Hariri Luck
says he lost
all of last year's
harvest due to the Russian invas
The fighting also destroyed his
silos and millions of dollars
worth of farm equipment this yea
The most important thing
now is to clear my fields, he sa
So that I can plant the next har
If farmers like Alexander
can't do their jobs.
The world could see another year
of soaring global food prices
Now, Aaron, we saw global
food prices soar last year, in p
because Russia blockaded Ukraini
They couldn't get their grain ou
to markets and the concern now
is that farmers like Alexander,
they just can't plant their fiel
because of the landmines.
The U.S.
government, the State Department
has committed $91 million
to the Ukrainian government
to double
the number of miners out there
clearing fields.
But this is a huge job.
We're talking about an estimated
that's the size of Virginia, Mar
and Connecticut combined.
And it's going to take a long ti
Consider this.
To this day in Western
Europe, farmers
are discovering unexploded
artillery shells
left over from World War One
more than 100 years ago.